a scary grandmother figure doling out
advice and punishment
feels like a familiar monster to a lot
of us which could be why today's monster
originally from russian and east slavic
folklore feels so ubiquitous
she's been the subject of operas comic
book story lines
children's books and cartoons and her
own films
not to mention hundreds of years of
folklore history
may i present baba yaga today she is
most commonly depicted as an
ugly evil witch but that wasn't always
her story
baba yaga was once more goddess than
witch who reigned over time
life death and the elements she was
associated with strong winds and dark
forests connected to the earth the
heavens and the underworld
she straddles the boundary between life
and death
so which witch is it elemental goddess
dark sorceress
terrifying granny let's find out
i'm dr emily zarka and this is monstrum
associated with powerful magic and
accused of cannibalism
she has immense powers over animals the
elements
and even time not all stories explicitly
depict baba yaga as an
ugly witch but most russians would she
is portrayed as a tall
gaunt old woman many tails reference her
bony leg
which might be severe thinness or it
might be a
literal skeleton leg she has disheveled
hair and a sometimes
iron nose that is so long she can lie
down on the floor of her hut
and it could touch the ceiling that
large nose allows her to identify her
visitors by scent
leading some folklorists to argue that
she's actually blind
the powerful yaga always lives somewhere
remote usually in a deep forest
her home while occasionally a grand
mansion is most often a hut
supported by chicken legs goat legs ram
horns or spindles
and is surrounded by a fence made from
human bones
with a lock on her gate made from the
sharp teeth of a human jaw
so you can see why people think she
might be a cannibal
the hut is constantly spinning and will
only stop with the chant
little house little house turn your back
to the forest your front to me
baba yaga's possessions are just as
mystical and complex
no flying broom for this switch the baba
yaga travels on a magical flying mortar
using a pestle to urge it on sweeping
away the path of her flight
with a broom she owns enchanted mirrors
that turn into lakes
combs that can transform into forests
handkerchiefs that become rivers
of flying carpet and fire-breathing
horses based on the etymology of her
name
baba yaga probably dates back to at
least the medieval period
and there are literally thousands of
baba yaga stories in russian and slavic
folklore
the first documented evidence of baba
yaga emerges in wood block
prints from the late 17th century and
early 18th century
indicating she was a known figure in
their early oral traditions
the first written mention of the baba
yaga is in the 1755 notes of a russian
grammar book
penned by poet and scientist mikhail v
lamonosov
he referred to iyagababa twice including
in a list comparing roman gods with
their slavic and russian correspondents
although she
is given no counterpart the first
narrative account of the baba yaga is in
vasily levchin's 1780 collection
russian fairy tales in which she is
depicted as terrifying and dangerous
with teeth like tusks and hands like
bear claws
until the 19th century baba yaga was a
largely eastern european monster
but she gained international recognition
when translations of alexander
aphanyasis 1855 to 1863 serial
publications
of 600 transcribed russian folk tales
appeared in the 1870s
his collection was styled like that of
the famed brothers grimm
though the inclusion of his sources and
the places where he heard the stories
lends greater scholarly legitimacy to
his work
later a russian illustrator used this
collection to create some of the most
famous renderings of russian folk
characters
including this one of the baba yaga in
1899.
she can be altruistic giving the
protagonist of the story gifts or advice
and even in the scariest stories when
she's a child kidnapper
a warrior witch or a cruel trickster the
protagonist
always escapes and despite her iron
teeth and associations with cannibalism
no one in baba yaga stories is ever
eaten
many baba yaga stories feature a young
protagonist just entering into adulthood
or marriage
in one such story a father gives his
daughter to baba yaga as a servant
the daughter completes her assigned
chores perfectly with the help of little
mice
impressed by her work baba yaga rewards
the girl with beautiful clothing
when the father checks to see if his
daughter is alive he is surprised to
find her very rich
he takes her home but her stepmother of
course there's an evil stepmother
is jealous so she sends her own daughter
to baba yaga but this girl
chases the mice with a rolling pin and
doesn't do any of the work required of
her
so baba yaga breaks her into pieces and
puts her bones in a box
not exactly evil not quite benevolent
there baba yaga
then there's one of the most beloved of
russian folk tales
vasilisa the beautiful on her deathbed a
merchant's wife gives a doll
to their only daughter vasalisa telling
her that she must always keep the doll
with her
if anything bad should happen to the
girl she has to give the doll food
and ask it's advice and the doll will
help her eventually vasalisa's father
remarries a widowed woman with daughters
of her own
and just like in the story of cinderella
vasalisa's new stepmother and sisters
are
far from kind jealous of her goodness
and her beauty
they do all they can to diminish her
allure with hard physical work
to their dismay vasalisa grows healthier
and more lovely
while the evil women grow uglier from
their spite but how does the girl
flourish despite their cruel actions
the doll every night secretly feeds the
doll and asks its advice
the doll comforts her and speaks wise
words and the next day
it does all of the girls work for her
when it's time for vasalisa to marry all
the bachelors pine for her hand
and the jealous stepmother grows even
more enraged
she moves them all to a new home near
the dense forest where baba yaga lives
one night vasalisa and her stepsisters
are working by candlelight when his
stepsister purposefully snuffs out the
light
and then instructs vasalisa to go to
baba yaga's hut for a new flame
scared of being eaten by baba yaga
vasalisa consults her doll
the doll's eyes glow and it says that as
long as it is with her
she will be safe so vasalisa sets off
for baba yaga's hut
once in the woods she is approached in
turns by three horsemen
first a man dressed in white atop a
white steed and accompanied by daybreak
next a man in red riding a red horse
behind whom the sun rises
at that moment a man clad in black with
an ebony stallion
seeming to beckon the oncoming night sky
disappears at baba yaga's gate
made of men's legs the bolts are arms
and the lock is a mouth with sharp teeth
the eyes and the skulls begin to shine
lighting the clearing as if it were day
she has arrived at baba yaga's hud
suddenly there is a horrible roar and
the terrifying woman
bursts out of the forest bravely
vasalisa bows deeply
asking for light as her stepsisters had
instructed
the baba yaga says she will give
vasalisa her light if she first does
some work for her
or she will eat her she gives vasalisa a
series of challenges
prepare a feast for 12 clean the
courtyard and house
prepare wheat wash linen and sweep
vasalisa feeds her doll and it does
everything but prepare the feast baba
yaga is surprised that someone can do
the tasks
and do them well satisfied that the girl
has fulfilled her side of the bargain
she sends the girl home with one of the
skulls with blazing
eyes vasalisa returns to her stepmother
and stepsisters burying the skull like a
candle
and they gratefully receive her having
been without fire for days
but flames shoot from the skull's eyes
and burn them to cinders
all except vasilisa of course who ends
up weaving linen
so fine she catches the eye of the czar
eventually becoming his bride
so baba yaga does have a heart but you
have to earn it
the story demonstrates baba yaga's power
over morning day
and night the three horsemen vasilisa
had seen and whom the baba yaga commands
it also gives us an idea of what purpose
the baba yaga tales might serve
you could argue that the experience
teaches the female audience how to be a
wife
to cook clean and sow at another
person's command
not all of the baba yaga's stories end
in marriage but they all show
an encounter with the old woman as an
initiation from childhood into adult
life
her tests and tasks for the protagonists
assess their cleverness and worthiness
as adults she plays a cultural role as
domestic instructor
demonstrating to young women and men
what moving to a new household is like
and what tasks they need to master to
become eligible husbands and wives
here's where we can further examine the
origins of the name baba yaga
her name might even hint at her possible
origins as a deity
while there are variations the word baba
originally referred to a married peasant
woman of childbearing age or older
and in old russian it was used for
midwives sorceresses and fortune tellers
in modern usage baba is a derogatory
term designating a difficult old woman
which could be connected to the image of
the baba yaga
in a few indigenous eastern european
languages baba is also the name for
pelican maybe that explains the baba
yaga's long beak-like nose and her hut's
chicken legs
yaga is harder to pin down and there
isn't a scholarly consensus on the words
etymology
some say it meant horrible or horrifying
at one point
while others connect it to the russian
verb meaning to ride
or we may find its origins in the early
latin for snake
but yaga is most commonly interpreted as
baba witch
old granny witch or evil baba if we look
at the variants of her name that use
iaga
there are more theories including
association with words for disease
illness horror or rage that said many
names for ancient slavic deities have
been lost over time
and this may be the case for baba yaga
perhaps the moniker is a substitute for
her original name
that was once so sacred or feared likely
both
that it could not be said out loud and
is now lost to history
attempts to explain baba yaga in the
18th century actually make this
association with ancient slavic deities
as well
including early indications that she was
a pagan goddess
after all she is associated with
supernatural powers
and magical gifts and has power over
life and death
like traits no except for that whole
chicken-footed hut deal
but there might be a more rational
explanation for the appearance of baba
yaga's house
nomadic hunters in siberia built
storehouses on top of tree stumps to
deter
animal foraging structures like the
swedish sammy storehouse and british
saddle stones
are similar in form and function and may
explain why baba yaga's hut was on
chicken legs and as i always want to
know what was the most common burial
practice in neolithic central europe
bodies were placed on wooden platforms
raised up on poles
so the corpses could dry out and the
bones preserved
which calls to mind depictions of baba
yaga's hut as well
that certainly associates her with death
as do all those bones surrounding her
home
and well the threatening to eat people
the mortar and pestle that baba yaga
uses to get around
they were essential tools for the
everyday tasks women were in charge of
in slavic culture
like preparing food and grain and making
medicine a lot of folklorists argue that
they have a sexual symbolism as well
but i'll let you google that in modern
depictions baba yaga began to serve as a
tool for socialist propaganda
the heroes and heroines in these baba
yaga tales carry over from the folklore
because of problem-solving hard work and
courage they exhibit
these were also traits the former soviet
union desired its citizens to have
and baba yaga was a popular character on
film and television
but baba yaga found global recognition
after the fall of the soviet union in
1991
and since then the baba yaga appeared in
the hellboy comics and movies
television shows like lost girl the
magicians supernatural
and arthur she's even in fortnite
mother bone breaker helper goddess witch
baba yaga is all of these things telling
stories was an essential part of life
for the east slavic and russian peoples
whose folklore was popular in all social
classes
it was customary to telescosca folk
tales at feasts and weddings
as well as share them during times of
work or rest at home
and baba yaga was and still is one of
the most popular characters
as grandmotherly advisor or
cannibalistic witch pagan earth goddess
baba yaga is a paradox
which might be why she's so fascinating
and even beloved
i'm going to quote andreas johns who
wrote this
incredibly thorough book on baba yaga it
is clear that there could be no
single correct interpretation or
understanding of babayaka
and there's actually a great freedom in
that both for us
as we conjure whichever version of baba
yaga that suits us best
and for the legendary woman and her own
powerful potential
so the trick is to keep me slightly over
caffeinated
i cannot get over the fact that in the
john wick movies
he's called baba yaga which they
translate to boogie man
no offense to keanu reeves but
i would love to be a consultant for john
wick four i think they're on now
hire me